we spend a lot of efforts obviously on
reducing our packing materials and we've
reduced well over 20 percent since 2010
by light weighting by moving out of
packaging etc and then we have already a
fairly high percentage of reused you
reusable plastic in our materials and we
think that with our own habits and
efforts about 40% of our plastic gets
recycled but unfortunately on a global
basis which is obviously what counts for
the future of mankind it's only 14% now
you're aiming to do this by 2025 that
sounds a long time in the future it is a
long way out or it is not a long way out
we're in 2017 now and some of the things
need to have required technology for
example these pouches are incredibly
efficient they are lightweight plastics
but they are laminated often for the
products that go in it or the climates
in which they are sold and there simply
aren't technical solutions yet and even
if Unilever alone would have these
technical solutions you have to drive
them at scale by involving others one of
the reasons why we make many of our
technologies actually available for the
public at large but you need to invest
in machines you need to get other
companies on board
you still need to set up the
infrastructures to to collect them so
yeah it will take a little bit of time
but I think the key thing is that we've
set a clear direction that others join
us and that we increasingly get critical
mass of this recyclable plastic to
justify investing in the recycling
industry in the first place how much is
this gonna cost you well we think as I
mentioned before that if we move truly
to a circular economy that the savings
would be there the 80 to 120 billion
that you would save in packaging in fact
any packaging that you buy right now
anywhere in the world on average 95%
would not be reused that is really an
unfortunate way that we're behaving that
way so I think if we can get more into
the consumer habits that we would all
expect from each other if we can set up
at an accelerated rate the recycling
industries we would actually make
savings fairly quickly and where that is
already the case we actually see the
being in favor of moving in this
direction you mentioned that you want to
be industry-leading how do you judge the
efforts of the rest of the consumer
goods industry compared with Unilever
well the packaging industry is obviously
broad everybody is in packaging so even
if you take a company like Unilever
which the best of our efforts were a
pimple in the total and so organizing
the industry at scale is a challenge
we've created the global consumer goods
forum which has all the major retailers
and manufacturers together this is a
forum that has made commitments to go
out of illegal deforestation in their
supply chain palm soy beef pulp
this is an industry that has made
commitments to go to natural
refrigerants for ice cream cabinets or
for the beverage cabinets and now again
it's an industry that hopefully will
make a firm commitment to move fast to
recyclable plastic wouldn't it be better
if we all just consumed a little less in
our daily lives
oh absolutely I would not disagree with
that at all and one of the initiatives
that we obviously continue to drive is
be sure that products are fully used in
bottles if you know by your Hellmann's
mayonnaise a-- and the upside down
squeeze bottle all the product comes out
so we don't have to waste we've reduced
the the plastic that we use in final
consumer usage you really want to have
the right products that truly add value
to the consumer but ultimately we need
to consume differently I would say the
UK government has introduced a tax on
the use of plastic bags would you like
to see a tax introduced
similarly on single-use plastic
containers it's a good example where you
see that the consumer themselves did not
get out of the habits I've always used
our crates or my wife's bag that she
carries with her so we've never been
very enticed in in a lot of plastic bags
but it was very hard to get consumers
out of it until we started charging for
it in some countries they even went as
far as banning plastic bags and
consumers find other alternatives so yes
we do need governments to be with us in
this to figure out what the most
effective ways are to change consumer
habits